[Music]
is Sharon Stone engaged for me something
tall and muscular the six-year-old
mosaic actress sparked rumours on
Thursday after she was photographed
rocking major bling on that signature
ring finger during a beach day in Miami
with boyfriend Angelo Bopha the two who
were first spotted out and about
together in New York back in January
looked adorable and in love as they
lounged in the Sun I don't even know
what to say
stone stunned and a colorful halter
bikini top
seersucker pants and stylish Sonny's
with their short blonde locks pulled
back in a headband meanwhile Bopha
played it cool opting for a shirtless
look paired with short denim shorts and
a brown leather belt like stone he also
sported a headband if stone and Bopha do
in fact tie the knot it will be stones
third marriage last May the actress who
has three adopted children told et how
being a mom has affected her love life
are you looking for love I don't know
and I don't think that looking is
finding I really feel that there's a
propinquity to the way that love comes
into people's lives it's a there's a
certain magic to it I have so much in
love with my kids et has reached out to
Stone's rep for comment
[Music]